- Ew, I hate that noise. It's so gross.
(laughter)
- Today we're going to be
painting each other naked.
- Wait, what?
- Just kidding, drunk. Even better.
- I think I've known Clark as
long as I've been working here
So two years in now.
I suck at painting, I am not a Picasso.
- I need alcohol.
- I think so.
- I think it's time.
- Those are some cute-ass
wine glasses man!
- Those are some big-ass wine glasses.
- [Brenda] Wine please.
About time, thank you.
- Cheers.
- Let's get started, bitches.
(classical music)
- Cha cha cha.
Paint paint paint, bitches.
- Paint paint paint.
- I feel like this canvas
looked prettier blank.
- Brenda, would you let
me cut your ear off?
- You know, it depends on the
amount of money you offer.
- You look like Mozart or
Bach or Beethoven or someone.
I'm so sorry.
- It's okay. I am not offended.
- You know what would be cute?
- What?
- Is if we took a tequila shot.
- Oh my gosh, should we?
- Aw man.
- [Jade] That one got you?
- That got me.
- Tequila!
- Oh my god, three, two, one, go.
- That's what best friends
do, drink together.
Fuck the portraits.
- [Brenda] Oh, your nose
just took an epic turn.
(both laugh)
- [Clark] I kinda vibe with this.
- It's like, forget what
people's perception is of you.
- Brenda, turn to me.
Brenda! Turn to me.
- Don't let society say
what you look and feel like.
- Come on.
- Feed me, mommy!
Shit got fucking weird.
- Life is spontaneous bro,
life is just flicking paint
and just doing whatever
it feels in the motions.
- Exactly.
- [Vaughn] Whatever. I'm like
not like thrilled with it.
You look a little bit like an alien.
- Am I covered in paint?
- Yeah you got so many splashes
in your hair and your face.
- [Vaughn] Brenda, I have
something I wanna show you.
- Oh god.
- Okay.
(Vaughn and Brenda laugh)
- I haven't looked at Clark's.
I'm excited to see what it is.
- Should we trade?
(Clark and Jade laugh)
- Oh my god, first of
all, that's fucking cute.
- I love that, man. That's dope!
- This is awesome!
(Brenda laughs)
- You've definitely taken
some artistic liberties.
- It's kinda fun to put your
thoughts down about your friend
in a different way, oh
you're great, you're funny,
you're kind, but like show that
shit through a painting, bro
- Doing something for
fun was pretty special.
To dedicate time to everything
that makes him so awesome and cool.
- Dammit, Clark, you're
making me emotional.
- Where's my wine?
- Should I just pour wine on this?
- I think so.
- [Brenda] Oh my god!
Oh my god!
- It's crying wine!
That's cool.
- [Brenda] That's really cool.
- Drunk...
- ...Friends.
Out.
(upbeat music)